[Musique]
salut les les loulous alors je suis un
boomer
beam me voilà sur tik tok
alors je vais bien tout bouille av avec
ce conte sur lequel vous retrouverez
mais célèbre tuto et ouais je vais
d'être sacha call tellement je suis bg
maman seydoux yav le mou
salut les amis
à
mois de mai
c'est et lycées
[Musique]
et
à
ce
succès
vient d'acheter le meilleur produit en
fait ça vous mettez dedans pour qu'elle
fuit après vous pouvez faire ce prix de
frites regardez je vais vous montrer le
jury va aller là dedans et ensuite et
ensuite on pourra faire ce prix de prise
sur nos produits offrent garder et après
je ris frites
ça va
oh c'est trop stylé à temps